the David Pakman show subreddit now has nearly
15,000 of our audience members subscribed
and participating in political discussion,
news discussions, suggesting stories for the
show. You can find the subreddit@davidpakman.com
slash R E. D. D. I. T. a couple of notable
threads I noticed this morning. One is from
a user named future Microsoft guy who says
sudden anti Warren videos from progressive
YouTube outlets asking what has caused all
the sudden anti Warren videos.
Think it has to do with where she is in the
polls. Kyle Kalinsky and Jimmy doré made
some points but seems it was brought on more
so due to poll numbers being better than Bernie.
What does everyone make of this? Listen here.
Here's the reality. I, I've tried to tell
this like it is from the beginning. lizabeth
Warren is not as progressive as Bernie Sanders.
Her political origins are far more conservative
than the origins of Bernie Sanders. Where
she ends up today on policy is to the right
of Bernie Sanders. But I'm not going to smear
lizabeth Warren. I've reported, she said in
the general she would accept money from sources
that Bernie Sanders would not, I forget the
exact list. If it's PAX corporations, whatever
it is, her position is she's not going to
participate in unilateral disarmament. If
the other side, if she is the nominee, uh,
she's not going to jeopardize her chances
of winning as she sees that.
You can disagree with that. I think there
are serious moral questions to that position.
Uh, there are differences between Bernie and
Warren on Medicare for all. Bernie is all
for it with a specific plan. lizabeth Warren
is into the idea, but claims there is not
a specific plan and is open to other options.
I've been totally transparent about it, but
either either of them would be the most progressive
presidents that the nited States has ever
had in the modern political era. And I don't
know what other shows are doing. I don't watch
other shows, but I'm not going to participate
in smearing lizabeth Warren when she would
be the most progressive president we've ever
had. Bernie would be more progressive. Sure.
But I'm not going to participate in what this
person says is happening on other, other channels,
which I have not seen. I just don't watch
other shows like this ne. I watch other stuff.
Uh, another post from the subreddit Tulsi
Tulsi Gabbard comes out against impeachment
proceedings. Um, and a lot of people are furious
about this. Listen, I am going to address
the Tulsi things sort of, I don't really care
what Tulsi does like, I mean, I, I know that
there's a big cult of personality around Tulsi
Gabbert. She is ne of our hundred and thirty
five members of Congress. There are like ighteen
Democrats, I think, who are not in favor of
the impeachment inquiry against onald Trump.
I quite frankly find myself relatively unmoved.
Like, okay, she's not for it. I just don't
care. In the same way that I wouldn't care
if bill de was against it or, uh, Hulu, Yon
Castro or anybody else who has no shot at
the democratic nomination. I just had a really
hard time even getting upset or concerned
about what Tulsi Gavin's position is. She's
not for it, you know, good for her.
Join the iscussion at David Pakman dot com
slash R. E. D. D. I. T.